When it premiered on ABC in September of 1993,
NYPD Blue made television history with its
gritty portrayal of the exploits of Manhattan's
15th police precinct.
Using documentary-style camerawork and a healthy
dose of PG-13 material, creators Steven Bochco
and David Milch ushered network television
into a bold new era of creative storytelling.
During its 12-season run, the show formed
a solid ensemble of talented actors, many
of whom got their big break on the critically
acclaimed series.
Let's look back at some of the most notable
NYPD Blue cast members and discover what they've
been up to since turning in their badges.
David Caruso
Prior to busting perps as Detective John Kelly,
David Caruso had a solid career, from playing
a cop in Rambo: First Blood, to playing a
gang leader in Bochco's groundbreaking series
Hill Street Blues.
The success of NYPD Blue launched Caruso onto
the A list — and he famously left the show
after the first season to star in forgettable
films like Kiss of Death… which pretty much
described Caruso's attempts at big-screen
stardom.
Caruso revitalized his career by returning
to TV for 10 seasons of CSI: Miami.
As Lieutenant Horatio Caine, his penchant
for puns and dark sunglasses achieved pretty
epic meme status.
"Friend said she came down to drink mojitos
and catch some sun."
"Well it looks like… something… caught
caught her."
Caruso has kept a low profile since CSI: Miami
ended in 2012.
Steven Bochco later opened up about his tumultuous
working relationship with Caruso, calling
the star's behavior on the NYPD Blue set "cancerous"
and alleging he had outrageous demands, like
$100,000 per episode and a 38-ft trailer.
Dennis Franz
Though he's forever associated with cantankerous
recovering alcoholic Detective Andy Sipowicz,
Franz previously played the equally irritable
Lt. Norman Buntz on Hill Street Blues... and
its forgotten fish-out-of-water comedy spinoff
Beverly Hills Buntz.
As Sipowicz, Franz scored four Emmys, and
one memorable nude shower scene.
Following NYPD Blue's final season, Franz
left showbiz to focus on a quiet life that
presumably doesn't involve smacking suspects
with phone books.
He resurfaced at the 2016 Emmys, reuniting
with former costar Jimmy Smits to the delight
of fans.
Maybe it's time for Netflix to greenlight
Sipowicz: The Frickin' Golden Years.
Jimmy Smits
L.A. Law star Jimmy Smits joined the cast
of NYPD Blue in season two as Sipowicz's partner
Bobby Simone, after Caruso's John Kelly resigned
from the force.
Simone's tragic death from a heart condition
made for one of the most moving episodes of
the series.
Smits, on the other hand, is alive and well,
and recently appeared as Senator Donovan on
24: Legacy.
Smits also had memorable runs on shows like
The West Wing, Sons of Anarchy and Dexter.
He also returned to the character he played
in the Star Wars prequels, Senator Bail Organa,
for 2016's hit film Rogue One.
But the best role he's ever played?
Johnny Wilson, Conky Repairman, on Pee-Wee's
playhouse:
"Johnny Wilson, authorized Conky repairman
at your service, Miss?"
"Yvonne."
"Where's my..."
"Is that a wrench in your pocket?"
"Ah!
That's a wrench!
Thank you very much."
Kim Delaney
Actress Kim Delaney brought grit to the role
of Detective Diane Russell, whose battles
with alcoholism and tumultuous relationships
with fellow cops made for some juicy storylines.
The part earned Delaney an Emmy for Best Supporting
Actress.
After leaving Blue, Delaney took the lead
role on Steven Bochco's short-lived legal
drama Philly and had a brief run opposite
David Caruso on CSI: Miami.
Following six seasons on the Lifetime series
Army Wives, Delaney again reunited with Bochco
for a role on his TNT series Murder in the
First.
Mark-Paul Gosselaar
Fans were surprised when Zack Morris himself,
Mark-Paul Gosselaar, joined NYPD Blue in season
9 as a replacement for departed cast member
Rick Schroder.
Gosselaar's Detective John Clark held his
own opposite the cast and remained with the
show until it came to an end in 2005.
Who knew Gosselaar would prove to be the best
actor among the Bayside bunch?
With roles on everything from Franklin and
Bash to the FOX baseball series Pitch, Gosselaar
has remained a reliable presence on the small
screen.
He also relived his giant cellphone-toting
days in a Saved by the Bell reunion on The
Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon.
Gordon Clapp
With his constant motormouth and awkward demeanor,
Detective Greg Medavoy brought comic relief
to the 15th precinct.
A regular on NYPD Blue throughout its entire
run, Medavoy grew to be a fan favorite and
an Emmy winner.
Gordon Clapp continues to work in theater,
earning a Tony nomination for Glengarry Glen
Ross on Broadway, and on shows like Damages
and Elementary.
These days he has a recurring role as Chaplain
Orlovsky on Chicago Fire.
Nicholas Turturro
John Turturro's younger brother made a name
for himself on NYPD Blue, scoring an Emmy
nomination for his role as Detective James
Martinez.
Martinez was a crucial part of the squad before
being promoted to sergeant in season 7 and
saying goodbye to the 15th precinct.
Turturro returned to the "blue" brotherhood
for his role as Sgt.
Renzulli on CBS' Blue Bloods, and his voice
can be heard as the ghostly superhero Deadman
in the Justice League Dark animated movie.
"Batman's head of me?
Sweet!
Tell him I'm a fan of his too."
He also showed off his comedic chops in films
like Paul Blart: Mall Cop 2 and Bucky Larson:
Born to Be a Star.
James McDaniel
As Lieutenant Arthur Fancy, James McDaniel
held the 15th Precinct together with his calm
yet commanding presence, eventually being
promoted to captain.
McDaniel left the show after season eight,
and while the precinct had other captains,
they don't hold a candle to McDaniel.
With a deep resume that includes theatrical
productions and films like Malcolm X and TV
shows like Sleepy Hollow and The Good Wife,
McDaniel has kept busy since hanging up his
gun and shield.
He also has the dubious distinction of having
starred on Steven Bochco's infamous musical
police procedural Cop Rock.
And rock it did not.
Henry Simmons
Joining Blue in its seventh season as Medavoy's
new partner Baldwin Jones, Henry Simmons was
one half of a formidable team, with Jones'
intensity and Medavoy's persistence working
in tandem to get confessions out of "skels."
Simmons is currently part of the Marvel TV
universe as Mack on Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
You may have also caught him on shows like
Ravenswood, and Man Up.
Bill Brochtrup
As P.A.A.
"Upstairs" John Irvin, Bill Brochtrup brought
heart, diversity, and subtle humor to what
could have been a thankless, forgettable role.
Prior to Blue, Brochtrup was a regular on
Steven Bochco shows like Total Security and
the doomed cop comedy Public Morals.
These days Brochtrup keeps busy in the theater
world and brings the same sensitivity he brought
to John to his role as psychologist Dr. Bowman
on TNT's Major Crimes.
Sharon Lawrence
ADA Sylvia Costas was on the receiving end
of one of Sipowicz's most memorably profane
rants in the pilot episode of NYPD Blue, but
she eventually fell for his gruff charms and
married the ol' lug.
Her murder during season six left Sipowicz
to raise their infant son alone.
Actress Sharon Lawrence, who scored three
Emmy Nominations for her role, left the series
in 1996 to costar with Leah Remini on the
short-lived NBC sitcom Fired Up.
A TV vet, she's had memorable roles on shows
like Desperate Housewives, Grey's Anatomy,
and Shameless.
Charlotte Ross
Prior to NYPD Blue, Charlotte Ross cut her
teeth in the soap opera world and starred
on the short-lived FOX musical drama The Heights.
She joined the cop drama in 2001, and made
a splash when her character Detective Connie
McDowell appeared partially nude in a controversial
2004 episode.
The sweet-natured McDowell would eventually
melt grumpy ol' Sipowicz's heart, and the
pair married and raised kids in the show's
later seasons.
Ross has kept busy on television since Blue
ended, with turns on shows like Glee and Nashville.
Arrow fans will recognize her as Felicity
Smoak's brassy mom Donna on the hit CW superhero
show.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!